my creative processes is really
exploring ideas that I'm interested in
at the time and then intensive research
which can become literal research and
abstract or abstract in terms of just
for more texture and shape and then I
build on on on on a woman three
dimensionally with fabric and form and
textures and sewing techniques that I
build in my studio and then I work with
my team on sort of building that out
into collection I mean I treat it you
know in acts as in a very theatrical way
in terms of the sequence of our
collection or show and where it starts
and where it begins or does it go in
reverse and backwards it's it's it's
like cooking a meal it's so varied I
often find my inspiration through
through through through play Gene Kelly
because he persevered and he and he was
he had no fear
well there's there's there's certain
pieces before clothing there's um the
snake goddess you know sort of page 4 of
gardeners or history book and you know
there's there's great clothing and
velasquez paintings and enjoy at
paintings and there's actual designers
which is only you know about a hundred
and fifty year old idea fashion designer
you know I really have incredible
admiration for a designer madeleine
vionnet and then it goes to cristóbal
balenciaga I mean so from there going
from real fluid forms or the invention
of glamour of looking at goddess like
women into sort of goddess forms because
they're just totally constructed
simplicity and from and they became
quite abstract there are large gestures
of personality in the clothing where
Vionnet was about bringing out the
character of the woman then from there I
go to see me aake and then to yohji
yamamoto eve solara he sort of resale
are created modern fashion the idea of
what a collection should feel like about
a couture vs ready-to-wear the formula
of what a fashion show should look like
and being in touch with with culture
bringing Street clothing into high
fashion you know he was you know I like
the dreamers then you know I go to John
Galliano who sort of revitalized
romanticism and dreaming I mean fashion
besides the utilitarian part of it is
not a necessity for people i mean it is
it is a
a you know thrill of life it's it's it's
not something necessarily necessary in
order to live in any way it's it's it's
it's an art form its its it has
patronage it has financial signifiers
attached to it so you know I like the
designers are sort of surpassed that or
make fun of that or or have that humor
or just great sculptors and creators I
think it's an amazing time in fashion
we're at a transition moment that
usually happens after the turning of the
century I think you know puppies babies
and you know plastic surgery or the new
fashion
you